hi guys so I'm back again with a
nightmare for you it's a lot of time
we're just getting to know the story all
the characters or the kids it looks
forget some sort of orphanage I haven't
actually looked it up because I don't
want any spoilers and found a weird
world that resembled Alice in Wonderland
we found Letty and we're kind of
exploring her past and then I ended up
beating the mushrooms and died so let's
carry on from there and not eat
mushrooms this time come back here again
I've saved the game so I won't go back
to the beginning again don't worry so
we're back here and I totally didn't
realize that there's a chest right by
the bed I'm such an idiot oh and there's
at the inside brilliant then I'm
syllabic a few oh I hear thought was
that chest damn it that would have been
too obvious let's booze oh okay buy a
book labeled mother Goose turn the pages
the Queen of Hearts the Queen of Hearts
she made some tarts all on a summer's
day the knave of Hearts he stole those
tarts and took them clean away the King
of Hearts called for the tarts and beat
the name full saw the knave of Hearts
brought back the tarts and bout he's
still no more oh I thought it was gonna
like do something now it's just a lovely
poem Oh something foul behind the bed
gold medal hell yeah tough draw give it
to the eyes you have metal insert back
where was back Oh top
left side medal wherever long Thank give
this obtained a snow boots crap
my mother isn't my real mother I have my
real mother passed away from an illness
the mother I have now often teases her
so I take the brunt of it for her I'm
responsible for all the heartful things
oh poor girl but when she's beating I
can't protect her wha eaten by who okay
it's empty so there's like her brother
I'd shake a spirit or something oh look
it's a kitty but I pay new dress new
Tetris sure oh ok oh this is fit a while
ok oh how do I know I wanted to turn you
around bloody thing no off is supposed
to turn you around right that doesn't
make sense
how do i turn you around
my suck
game over level 10 please don't say
after forget it that cuz I don't know
how to turn it around okay pick it up
obtain a shot of xxxx xxxx what the hell
is that who are you hmm i thirsty okay
is that dead lady oh oh wait she's
thirsty here's a water well draw water
maybe how to drink it like this put it
in the bucket Oh go back into the house
there must be a cup in there somewhere
okay so I've got water it's my cup on
the table take the cup in the cup great
so I've got sack up
and then I draw the water it keep curb
move the water to the death thank you
very much there's something by the well
obtained a note with scrap cool ones a
mother said we'd go for a walk I didn't
want to but she dragged me by the hand
into the forest dozens how good like
usual after walking a long way mothers
have we take a break you stay here she
told me i SAT there the whole time it
got dark I was scared it was pitch black
so she could try to get rid of her im
sue me I was so so scared so I closed my
eyes and I talked to him what's your
name what should be their food what
don't you like I was surprised he wasn't
like me at all oh so he probably has
like a little stirring he's looking
after her that's so cute poor girl
here you go water yeah water she'll see
she's dancing to the music dead okay
thanks I was really parched I think she
is tapping I woke up here but no one's
around I was too scared to move alum do
you know where this is and why we're
here a dream really is that right I was
surprised it looks exactly why I used to
live um Rick isn't here he's usually
always holding my hand in my dreams it's
really scary on my own Rick Allen that's
right I'm not alone Plus this is a dream
I can just wake up and things will go
back to normal okay let's play it's my
first time playing with someone else for
the dream sorry about the cars by the
way the words on the sign are two half
me to read because you're really Alan
yes because I read books stuff it seems
like some kind of riddle looks neat oh
and don't want too fast I'm a pretty
slow water don't leave me alone okay Oh
fine so needy what is that it's like a
little egg hmm okay hey Reed redesign
the two paths are very much like but
their ends are slightly different what
where are they different answer in
numbers one two three four five six okay
hmm tell me if you know who don't mess
up whoa you read it all you're amazing I
hate studying so I usually sneak away
its stead of time which makes teach a
mad oh but I can read clocks aren't I
great oh yeah sure that I'm amazing okay
right so this is what this one looks
like okay I'm just taking it all in
processing processing okay okay all
right and now this one oh my god I got
them in with the mushrooms was it was so
hard I'll edit this for you do I
hey I think is yeah 136 sweet okay take
this obtain the notebooks back cool what
is that I was a girl is this the deep
forest I should go back I'm fine but she
doesn't like living here she'll say it
grows as arouse again why does that
which have to tease her so I have to do
away with that evil which is that like a
real mom and the witches like her mama
I'm so confused right now what is that
Rick's not here Rick always talks to me
when I'm alone me and he teaches me all
this stuff I've never experienced myself
but it always seems a little sad except
when we're talking then he's having fun
I wonder why Alan do you have someone
important to you I don't know do you
have someone important to you he doesn't
I said no Elspeth further narrow us
really not anyone doesn't that make you
lonely that's probably a lot more simple
looking for something
haven't seen you before hello Alice my
name is Larry I'm not Alice so we're
both artists oh so original now you're
Alice killer says soon but I just said
that slide this what you're looking for
is that key oh my god Salek oh that's
creepy Rick he was lookin pretty tasty
so I thought I just eats him whoa I mean
really guys pretty broken first I got a
second month watch him a call that one
Rock two birds two birds one sting well
I've done what I did let's meet again in
30 ah he vanished Rick you're okay right
I'll hold your hand oh my gosh I
wouldn't hold his hands oh my gosh he
ate him lot of these little critters my
spiders probably spiders Oh pick up tain
chard okay what are these are things why
they're little sticks everywhere oh I
can't go to okey-dokey then wow what are
these sticks so weird still smells good
though that's good thing food mixer /
chocolate Hansel and Gretel the wit ah
it's all coming to me it's just like all
your fairy tales ah cool sorry garlic
and I'm getting excited I love chocolate
ah so I i love the banana chocolate from
hotel Charlotte oh my gosh it's so nice
okay what's on the table a key take it
keys are always a good sign oh I've got
a world key Olson this house looks just
like mine but it's all made of sweets
that's so dreamy also I wonder if it's
okay
take a bite no I wouldn't I wouldn't if
I were you teacher was there key don't
move sweet sweet so sweet what is he all
about ow ow ow I'm hungry does he want
the chocolate he wants a chocolate ok
let's give him some chocolate these
chocolate like massive chocolate drops
oh gosh I'm hungry now I'd want some
chocolate Your Mother Goose Punch and
Judy Punch and Judy fought for a pie
Punch and Judy Oh punch cave Judy and
knock in the eye says punch to Judy or
you have any more sisterly to punch my
eye is so that's were we seems like it's
made of cookies okay give him some
cookies oh this has a sweet candy send
so I'm good all other mushrooms have a
taste these are weird are you sure it's
okay should we eat them now okay
delicious yes they didn't care system
awesome cool nice oh okay hello who are
you nice to meet you why did you come
back you're always going down deep roads
you know at this point I can't care for
you you'll only get hurt more so why
even come back I don't like this rig
that name again Rick Rick is that her
mum or the witch who are you always
talking to you there's no one here but
me my husband and you disgusting what he
exists he definitely is this why how can
you I am sorry but I'm sorry I'm so whoa
evil witch why is it always always the
same thing with you I'll protect you
Lizzy you oh okay I'm gonna what am I
going to do I'm gonna jump in front of
lessee cuz I'm a gentleman and I died
never be a gentleman that as the moral
of this story oh gosh okay so i think
i'll leave it there for the time bein
and i'm definitely looking forward to
making another one as i said before give
me a thumbs up it really helps and
we know that you are enjoying this and
that you wanna see more as well so thank
you have a lovely day or evening bye why
don't you go Alan okay okay okay maybe
not it suddenly got dark I love using
soft I don't want to go anymore